but like to like you alluded like the
anime of it has increased exponentially
right there's a lot of
explosions devil jees everybody's on
steroids everybody out every everybody's
working out everybody beefy so initially
I was like yo it's almost too many
effects while fighting I'm like I
sometimes I can't even see the moves
that are coming because there's some
kind of sparkling effect or something
like that so I'm like okay but I asked I
asked Kai he says I can I can adjust
that on my end yes so I don't see all of
that and it looks like a more grounded
experience even though you know it's
online is playing out as as this crazy
you know bombastic experience because to
me that was the only thing where it's
like for whatever reason like it it was
just it was a little it threw me off
because I'm like man I'm I I can't see
the move I it felt kind of like and I
mind you I felt this way when Street
Fighter started doing it right